so joining me now Texas Republican
senator John Corin who is on the
Judiciary and intelligence committee
Senator thank you very much for being
here um at at the White House briefing
today uh Karine John Pierre was asked
about this situation and and here's what
she had to
say they're trying to politicize it and
make it worse make it worse that's what
Republicans are trying to do and make
turn it into a political stunt the
president is actually dealing with the
issue that's in front of him by getting
record funding 25,000 federal agents at
the border that is something that this
president has been able to do so is this
a republican stunt and is it about more
money
Senator no it's not just about uh more
money I've invited Senator Coons my
colleague and a number of a bipartisan
group to come with me to El Paso and
then to Mexico City to try to figure if
we we could come up with some critical
mass on Solutions but I for one I'm not
going to vote for a single more penny
for funding uh the current policies of
the Biden Administration which are
responsible for 11,000 people a day
currently showing up illegally at the
border then being sent into the interior
of the country never to be heard from
again and the reason why mayor Adams
statements down in South Central and
South America are not not going to go
anywhere because people who successfully
make their way into the interior are
calling their relatives and saying I
made it you can too they're watching TV
and seeing how the border patrol is
overwhelmed so uh this requires number
one enforcing the law which the B
Administration won't do and number two
changing the Asylum system so if you
Transit a safe Third Country then you
can't claim asylum in the United States
that would help take care of much of
this but of course there's more than
that to do do you think you could get
Democrats to sign on to
that I've been uh I've been begging and
pleading for for a long time but
unfortunately all I get is talk and no
action I've asked the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee Senator Durban from
Illinois whose Governor now says this is
a real problem in his state to work with
us to try to come up with a solution but
unfortunately he's refused to hold even
a markup which is where bills actually
are passed out of committee and
considered on the floor all right yeah
that's all talk and no action well that
that's a shame um because obviously
people are suffering in places all
across the country you know that better
than anyone in Texas Senator thank you
very much we look forward to hearing
about that trip uh let us know when
that's going to be and we will cover it
with the bipartisan trip thank you very
much Senator hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else